yeah what do you say what did he say
he wants us to send michael to hear the
proposition legendary actor james khan
dead at 82. according to a statement
released on khan's twitter he died on
the evening of july 6.
while the cause of death was not
revealed the statement includes a
message from his loved ones quote the
family appreciates the outpouring of
love and heartfelt condolences and asks
that you continue to respect their
privacy during this difficult time
what are you going to do
nice college boy yeah they want to get
mixed up in a family business khan born
and raised in new york city became a
household name after landing the part of
sunny in francis ford coppola's 1972 mob
drama the godfather he earned critical
acclaim for his performance nabbing
nominations at both the academy and
golden globe awards
in 1974 he transformed into sunny again
for the film sequel the godfather part
two
hey
everybody come on pay attention even
though he was a loon i mean he was
he was violently passionate e.t sat down
with khan in 1990 to reflect on the
career defining gig he said it's one
that's forever close to his heart it's
one of my
three i would say three favorite three
or four favorite roles i've played it
was certainly you know
certainly the most colorful
one
you know but i remember like you know as
all actors do when i first saw the
picture you know
i was so upset man
you know because you know actors you
know you get a little selfish because
you only look at you hey manny how come
he cut out that scene now can we cut out
that thing i'll come that part in there
i wasn't even gonna go to the party i
was so upset that'll beg me in the car
ah man he cut me out of the party you
know coming out of this scene and coming
i hate you francis you know so i didn't
know it was good
i never somebody told me it was good
then i was happy that same year khan
scored big again with misery a
psychological thriller based on the
stephen king novel
misery chastain cannot be dead
annie in 1871 women often died in
childbirth
but a spirit is the important thing and
misery's spirit is still alive it's
something i've never done i mean here
i'm a total victim right
usually i'm dishing it out pretty good
i'm a totally reactionary character
which was a major challenge and while
his expansive career favored more
serious roles he won the hearts of
audiences of all ages in the beloved
holiday classic elf i know you may be a
little um
[Music]
chemically imbalanced but you've been
right about a lot of things
i i don't want you to leave i never
really saw myself doing anything with
santa claus do you know what i mean
what i found about the script it had a
little edge to it i took the kids and
and some of my my friends and my mom
you know it's 88 and just everybody i
mean the grown-ups just kind of
felt good you know and had you know
they laughed khan is survived by his
five kids including actor scott khan who
told et in 1998 how his father felt
about him following in his acting
footsteps yeah i know he's proud you
know even if he
you know and he tells me he's proud but
you know he's a
he's a
he's proud